I'm Trish Sie and I'm directing Pitch Perfect 3
I want to take you around the set and give you a little sneak peek of what's coming.
We're taking you on global tour with the Bellas
Girl what's my weakness? Night shoots.
We're action stars here on set of.
Pitch Perfect 3
Getting attacked by dogs. I'm also allergic too. So great to be spending the day here
We're almost exactly halfway through our shoot right now
There are many people doing very important things here.
We are not any of them
Anna Camp is hilarious.
Rebel and John are just like peas in a pod and DJ. Khaled is amazing
He's a force of nature.
DJ Khaled will be in the big movie. Pitch Perfect 3
I am the most badass Bella.
I mean, I have to run at least 10 steps and this scene.
Last day of shooting Pitch Perfect 3....What?!?!
I've been crying all day
It's emotional
I'll miss you ladies.
You not gonna miss us 'caus we aint letting you go
How 'bout that?
We're all going to miss this.
It's been a wild ride.